okay so russian linked hackers massively
disrupting
the lifeblood of our economy america's
oil and gas supply
but don't worry because the bite
administration is tackling the really
big foreign policy crisis
2016 russian collusion the lie in fact
biden just hired one of america's
biggest
russia collusion truthers her name
susan hennessey to its national security
division
almost no one was more dedicated to
pushing these lies this russian hoax
these conspiracy theories and susan
hennessey in fact
she just tweeted oh around 39
000 tweets many of which were dedicated
to the russia collusion conspiracy
theories
and look at your screen this list was
put together by our friends at the
federalist as you can see hennessey one
of dozens of officials and media figures
that lied for three long years hawking
this life for three long years
pushing this hoax for three long years
none of these people should ever be
trusted again
none of them they're quite literally
conspiracy theorists
they hurt the country they lied to you
day in
and day out right to our faces all for
political gain
here with more is south carolina senator
lindsey graham
senator i i want to see if i understand
this and you see if
you tell me if there's a connection joe
biden starts funding the palestinians
again
lo and behold rocket fire into border
towns in gaza
coincidence joe biden gets rid of the
the deal with iran interesting they're
aligning with the russian and chinese to
fight
a proxy war my question is this you know
a lot about national security
do you think that these rogue nations
hostile regimes see joe biden as i do
i'm just one of the few people honest
enough to talk about
it do they see joe biden as weak do they
see him as frail
did they see him cognitively struggling
like i do
well their actions indicate that they're
not afraid of the united states i can't
imagine
eastern european countries russia
included
who allow cyber criminals to attack the
united states need to be put on notice
that you need to clean up your backyard
i like newt's idea of creating a
cyber terrorism list that these cyber
criminals who attack our critical
infrastructure
are really terrorist by any other name
and we need to amend our laws so that we
can treat them
as terrorists but i've never been more
concerned
about our national security than i am
now everybody sees
joe biden as weak we're going back into
the iran deal
the arabs and the israelis are beside
themselves iran is getting stronger
china is threatening us at every turn
and russia is
troops on the border of the ukraine so
this is a dangerous time
voids are filled when people are weak in
the united states when the american
president
is weak that empowers all the bad guys
and you see that happening every day on
the world stage
you got hammered a little bit over your
comments about donald trump
i'd say to my republican colleagues can
we move forward without president trump
the answer is no
but it's really we're talking about the
simple agenda
and you and i have discussed this at
length and that is okay what is
what do we conservatives believe liberty
freedom capitalism
lower taxes less government bureaucracy
we want free and fair trade we want
peace through strength secure borders
energy independence constitutionalists
on the bench
law and order safety security free
market solutions to health care
and choice in schools am i missing
anything because if i am i need to be
educated
now that's a pretty good american first
agenda you just described and
what i said on your show got people all
riled up but it's just common sense the
most popular republican in america
it's not lindsey graham it's not liz
cheney it's donald trump
people on our side of the aisle believe
that trump policies worked
they're disappointed that he lost and to
try to erase donald trump from the
republican party
is insane and the people who try to
erase him are going to wind up getting
erased
it's impossible for this party to move
forward without
president trump being its leader because
the people
who are conservative have chosen him as
their leader
and you know why they chose him because
he delivered he was the most
consequential president for national
security since ronald reagan
he secured the border you cut our taxes
you brought a new attitude
of being an american and the people have
chosen him
not not the pundits yeah by the way i
think tim scott might be the senior
citizen
uh senior senator now from the great
state of south carolina i'm just
guessing
after that rebuttal to biden and he you
know
right he's he's giving you a run for
your money just saying
and he's taking us fair heat forward
he's a smart one yeah
all right senator thank you he's a great
guy he's stronger today than he's ever
been thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else